um
foreign
possible
uh
videos
um
good afternoon distinguished colleagues
we are starting our today's briefing
under the conditions of a new
aggravation of the epidemic situation in
the world
which is reason for serious concern the
second wave of the pandemic most likely
is going to be
even more dangerous than the first one
we are talking about a global pandemic
the explosive growth of the infection
rates
is witnessed everywhere as we see from
the infection statistics and currently
we have over 40 million infected people
which means that there's an increased
loads on the hospitals which are
mobilized for the fight against the
coronavirus
in all the countries of the world
numerous international experts predict
another reduced trust for national
economies
which were only starting to recover
from the crisis
following the events of the spring
the director general of world health
organization paid special attention to
the increased rings
rapid spread of covey 19 together with
the spread of
traditional seasonal diseases the
european office of who also warns that
the current epidemic
outbreak is related with the lifting of
the measures for physical distancing
let me emphasize once again that these
are the variations of the world health
organization therefore
the who once again calls for
consolidated efforts to attack on the
pandemic
which would define the continued
trend of the disease whether it will be
more serious hoy whether it will go down
at the same time the un experts believe
that the anti-covet measures should be
taken
with the consideration of specific
circumstances the local conditions and
they should serve to protect the
population and
as well as the economy the search for
such smart formulas
is the main task for the governments of
the vast majority of states
we're especially concerned by the recent
aggravation of the sentry conditions in
a number of countries traditionally
visited by the russian tourists
according to ross patrapnodzor the
increased rise of covet-19 infection
rates in the united
arab emirates croatia slovenia and even
such relatively
safe countries such as egypt thailand
sexual islands maldives turkey
there is a risk of a so-called rollback
and actual risks of most unfavorable
scenarios of
the disease developments we once again
call our citizens to pay special
attention to the planning of their
foreign trips
and refrain from them and calculate all
the risks
beforehand
at home we once again
draw your attention to the
recommendations that had been made by
the operational hq the russian hq i mean
now we are moving on to the schedule of
the russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov
previously we had announced that on the
23rd of october
the minister will have a meeting with
the foreign minister of kyrgyzstan
during the talks the ministers will
discuss the prospects of
bilateral cooperation the participation
in the integration groups on the
eurasian space as well as the
implementation of the previously
achieved bilateral and multilateral
agreements
at the high and highest levels
special attention will be paid to the
issues of the year of russia and
kyrgyzstan and the year of kyrgyzstan
and russia
and numerous topics will also be covered
during the talks
next on the 26th of october the russian
foreign minister will pay a working
visit to greece
in athens the russian foreign minister
will hold talks with the foreign
minister of greece
as well as the prime minister of greece
and the leader of the leading opposition
party
coalition of radical left forces during
the contacts with the greek authorities
the minister will discuss measures to
intensify the political dialogue
as well as bilateral economic
cooperation cultural and humanitarian
links
there is also a planned exchange of use
on regional and
international topics including the
situation in eastern mediterranean the
middle east and north africa balkans and
caucasus they
he will also sign a memorandum on the
year of history of russia and greece in
2021 on the 28th of october the russian
foreign minister
sergey lavrov will pay a visit to boston
herzegovina
and meet the presidium of the country
and the deputy chair of the
national parliament and he will hold
talks with the
deputy prime minister the foreign
minister and he will also talk
have talks with the mr dodec and he
will also hold consultations between the
foreign ministries of our
countries the agenda of the visit
includes the development of the
bilateral links the
prospects of political trade and
economical humanitarian cooperation
on the eve of the 25th anniversary of
the framework agreement on peace and
bosnia's
governor signed in 1995
the minister will also discuss the
number of measures related to the
post-conflict settlement
with the focus on the principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
the country the equality of the
three peoples of the country and the two
ethnicities the republic
serps can the federation of bosnia
herzegovina with white
constitutional authorities and powers
the minister will also discuss this
situation in the balkan region and the
current
issues on the international agenda and
from the 20th to 29th of october the
russian foreign minister will pay a
visit to the republic of serbia
where he will have meeting with the
president of serbia as well as take part
in the ceremony
on the occasion of the finishing of the
internal declaration of the
church of saint sava and
and the eternal flame at the cemetery of
the liberators of belgrade
the minister will discuss the current
issues on the russian serbian agenda
exchange views on the current
international regional problems
including the
settlement of kosovo now moving on to
the current international issues
on the 24th of october it will be 75
years since this
nature of the charter of the united
nations which would
start the activities of this global
organization this anniversary is closely
linked
with another important date the 75th
anniversary of the end of
world war ii 75 years ago the countries
of the anti-hitler coalition
aspiring not to repeat the most
destructive tragedy in the history of
humanity were united by the idea of
building a fair and just world order
based on the respect for sovereignty the
interests and concerns of all states and
peoples
the role of this cornerstone of the
post-war
world order was given to the united
nations organization
it set down the principles of
international law including sovereign
equality non-interference into
internal affairs and the settlement of
conflicts by political and diplomatic
means in the years of its existence
the organization has faced serious
difficulties and challenges
and many countries try to
prevent it from its normal activities
but still it tasks
its task has been accomplished it
prevented another
planet-wide conflict on the occasion of
the 75th anniversary
on the 21st of september
the u.n general assembly held a
high-level event during which
a video address was played recorded by
the russian foreign minister in the name
of the
csto member states following the session
a relevant declaration was adopted with
a focus on the necessity to strengthen
the
true multiple world order based on
the compliance with the un charter and
other international rules and norms
the organization platform
plans a number of other commemorative
events but due to the pandemic they had
to be delayed until a later date
the anniversary initiatives in new york
were planned and they included
commemorative events organized by the
russian federation
russia together with the information
center of the u.n in moscow planned to
organize a series of scientific
conferences
roundtable discussions as well as
a concert in the radio concert hall in
moscow
which will also delay due to the
epidemic situation
at the same time on the 10th of october
gimmo university hosts the video opening
of the international moscow un model
named after
mr churkin on the anniversary of this
united nations organization and today
the state doom of the russian federation
held a roundtable discussion
with a report read by
sergey version deputy foreign minister
of the russian federation who talked
about the
main steps in the development of the
united nations he emphasized the
importance of the organization in
today's world
a month earlier
the stay douma of the russian federation
released a document which emphasized the
support for the global organization as a
central coordinating
body of the international agenda and
international affairs
the document emphasized the importance
to prevent the domination of certain
countries in the international agenda
our countries also released
commemorative postmarks and coins
on the occasion of the 75th anniversary
of the un as one of the founding states
and as a permanent member of the
security council russia will continue
contributing to
increasing the authority of the
organization as a universal platform
to find collective answers to the
challenges and threats of our times
we are open to constructive work in this
area with all
like-minded countries
moving on to the sentence of the
conflict in nagorno-karabakh
we continue our
liaison and intermediary efforts aim to
stop the conflict
in nagorno-karabakh the issues of
nagorno-karabakh
conflict settlements were discussed on
the 20th and 21st of october in moscow
during separate meetings between the
foreign ministers of russia sergey
lavrov and the minister
foreign affairs of azerbaijan and
foreign minister of armenia
as always we're working within the osce
minsk format
another meeting is planned tomorrow in
washington moving on to the development
of the situation in syria
we see opposing trends in the country on
one hand
we see good results to normalize the
situation on the other hand
unfortunately the destructive forces are
also trying to
undermine the existing processes we've
see can
continue to implementation of the
supplementary russian turkish protocol
to the memorandum on the stabilization
on
the idlib zone in accordance with the
existing agreements the turkish
military forces have started
patrolling the turkish control zones of
syria in particular
the moral locality in the west of the
hama province at the same time the
situation in the northeast of syria
gives us numerous reasons for concern in
particular we have see
taken note of the provocative statement
of the co-chair of
executive council of the council for
democratic syria
saying that russia supposedly failed its
mission as a guarantor between the talks
between rajava and the syrian government
it is worth noting that following his
accusations against our country
on the 16th of october another large
u.s military convoy arrived to the
transit ratio from iraq
we are witnessing unceasing attempts of
washington to
detach the kurds from the
multi-confessional syrian state
heating up the separatist sentiment we
have numerous questions concerning the
recently adopted decision to release
about 600 isil fighters from the prisons
in north east of syria
it is apparent that the kurds only did
this on the hint from the americans
and there were very dangerous
consequences
from this tap
we already received information saying
that we
witness increased activities of islamist
radicals
which infiltrate the
government-controlled regions
and start clashes with the local
military forces
we emphasize russia's principal position
and our support for the unity of syrian
respect for its territorial integrity
and sovereignty
we call damascus as well as the
self-proclaimed authorities of the
northeast of the country to constructive
dialogue in order to find mutually
acceptable solutions in the interests of
the local population and the entire
country
we take note of the efforts of the
syrian government to provide assistance
for the repatriation of the refugees as
you know since 2018 there is a campaign
for repatriation of the syrians actively
supported by the russian federation
within this process the president of
syria
has signed several orders on amnesty
and also carried out procedures to
settle the legal status of the citizens
who were forced to leave their country
due to the war
even though the task of establishing
safe
conditions for the voluntary
repatriation of the refugees
and internally displaced persons is
clearly stated in resolution 2254 of the
un
security council the international
contribution remains rather modest
the syrian authorities are planning to
organize an international
conference on the repatriation of syrian
refugees and internally displaced
persons on the 11th and 12th of november
in
damascus syria has already sent
invitations to a large number of states
and international organizations russia
is a co-organizer of this forum we see
it as a
platform for substantial discussion of a
range of issues related with the
assistance to syrians
in their repatriation in coming back
home and restoring the unity of the
syrian people and we hope that
the international community will get
actively involved in solving this
humanitarian issue
now moving on to the elections in
bolivia which took place on the 18th of
october we are talking about
the elections in the multinational
multi-ethnic
state this was a general election
without any serious violation
everything was peaceful and resulted in
the
socialist party victory led by
kotakorra and on the 21st of october the
russian president sent a congratulatory
telegram to the president
the elections marked an end of the
period of
legal uncertainty which started almost a
year ago following a violent
resignation of eva morales
and those events had all the features of
a coup d'etat
we see that the current elections
confirmed that the political project
that was implemented in bolivia for the
last 15 years
is adapting to the modern reality and is
supported by the majority of the
country's population
in this context we see great importance
in the calls of new bolivian authorities
to find
common points of various political
forces to overcome the political split
that happened in the recent year the
outcome
of the bolivian election lets us make
another very
significant and important conclusion
that the national interests and the
popular wisdom can overcome any attempts
of political engineering
including attempts imposed from abroad
this is a lesson that we can learn from
the bolivians
it has importance for exceeding the
national borders we congratulate
we believe in president and the bolivian
people
this was a democratic and peaceful
election we wish
constructive development and peace to
the country we confirm our readiness to
promote political dialogue and mutually
beneficial
commercial and economic cooperation in
the energy
sector in agriculture in science and
technology and humanitarian and other
areas of mutual interest of our
countries
we also continue closely monitoring the
situation in mali
we are satisfied to note significant
progress that has been achieved at the
talks between the
ecowas and the military in bamako
and the modalities of the transition
period
which manifested in the appointment of
the ad hoc president and prime minister
and establishment of the government
involving the leading political forces
of the country
and the national council meant to act as
a parliament
is currently being formed
we believe that the new authorities of
this state will take all the necessary
measures
to normalize the internal political
situation
to make sure the country comes back to a
constitutional order
we hope that the country will come back
to civilian governance
following general elections with the
participation of aquas
and the african union at the same time
we are seriously concerned by the
degradation of the security situation in
mali
against the background of the kov 19
spread
and the power vacuum certain isil and
al-qaeda-affiliated extremist groups are
building up their activities especially
in the central and northern provinces of
the country
which are experienced survey of
terrorist attacks against the military
and the civilians on the 16th of october
the u.n security council
agreed on the state release and press
release on
the death of the egyptian peace
keeper of the u.n mission in mali
in the region of kidal following an
attack
on the camp in tambuktu like to express
our condolences to the family
of the victim of the attack to egypt and
to the mission of the united nations we
highly appreciate the
activities of the u.n mission which is
one of the main elements of
security in this state unfortunately the
blue helmets together with the armed
forces of
the sahel's own countries and the local
civilians continue suffering from
terrorist attacks
this year 23 u.n peacekeepers were
killed in their fights against the
local terrorists we condemn any attacks
against the blue helmets and we call the
local authorities to
to prosecute those who
carried out those attacks the u.n
mission is the most dangerous
mission of the united nations therefore
we call for adopting additional security
measures and russia will continue
its constructive participation as a
permanent member of the young security
council
in the collective efforts to stabilize
the situation mali and sahara sahel
region we will continue providing
assistance to the countries of the
region on a bilateral basis
including supporting the increasing the
battle readiness of the local military
and the law enforcement agencies
states and iran haven't been defeated
twice
in the united nations security council
the united states
have been persistent in the anti-iranian
policy promising to
punish those countries who
do not agree with the u.s policy of
exercise and maximum pressure onto iran
trying to revenge
washington to decide it
to use unilateral sanctions against
those who cooperate with iran
and military technicals fear in this
context is only one
element judging upon these statements by
state secretary pompeo on the 21st of
october during the briefing
understood the purpose of the united
states was to
seizing international cooperation with
the islamic republic unfortunately
the attacks and threats by the united
states
against a number of countries russian
organizations including the united
nations
uh showed that
washington places its anti-iranic
sentiments higher and
above the international law and the
decisions of the security council
such a behavior is not uh acceptable and
is not worth
a great power we are convinced that the
world will not let the united states
replace international law with
some one-time political ideas
it is clear for everyone that
the manipulation of the iranian threat
serves selfish interests of the american
military complex
if the americans want
to hide from the whole world
and hide their inability to
achieve any agreements
we still independently choose
our partners that are important to us
and the cooperation with whom
is beneficial for our country
our consulate cooperation is based upon
the relations
of good neighboring as
for military technical cooperation the
russian policy in this area corresponds
completely
to the norms of the international law
and it
corresponds completely to the russian
legislation
which is quite rigorous and it
doesn't depend on
political interests and there is another
topic of
a great interest i am talking about the
united
nations accusations of
hacker attacks
supposed to russian hackers who
tried to undermine the olympic games in
tokyo
what i want to say that the coronavirus
infection and pandemic
revealed that all the countries are
vulnerable in front of the common
thread and the whole reasonable world
community
tries to establish mutually beneficial
cooperation in the area of
uh international information security
and try to overcome the
cyber pandemic other countries
are still trying to accuse russia of
some crimes
in the information area that's how we
perceive the
accusations by the united states of
russian citizens in hacker attacks
those accusations were announced
in public and they were published
on the british foreign ministry
website i will not be surprised
if later on they
say that the olympic games
would have been postponed because of the
actions of russian hackers
as the united states sorry the united
nations the secretary general
said we live in the world of the
information pandemic as well
and emit the statements
by the u.s on russian almighty
hackers we would like to highlight that
we constantly propose to organize expert
meetings
to discuss all those claims
but the united nations united states and
their allies
try to fake some ideas
about the russian interference
which is quite ridiculous we would like
to recall once again to the authors of
this
campaign that
amid the spread of the coronavirus
infection it is necessary to focus on
the international cooperation in order
to fight against
cyber pandemic and not to do the
opposite thus aggravating
mistrust in the global information
domain
i would also like to comment on
the situation with the exercises
in germany in the framework of joint
nuclear missions of nato we paid
attention to
in the information and mass media on
holding of
nato uh exercises called steadfast
noon in the second decade of octobers in
germany
the names of western campaigns and many
western operations are quite outstanding
and i would like to prepare
a list of them
well according to the the information we
have
these uh exercises involve
the training in using nuclear weapons in
the framework of the so-called joint
nuclear missions of the alliance
the american nuclear weapons deployed
in europe remain not only in germany but
also in belgium the netherlands
italy and turkey at the same time the
americans
update in their nuclear bombs and the
european nato members
their aircraft delivering such weapons
would like to point out that uh in the
conditions of crisis situation in the
area of arms control
the unlimited built up by several states
and their allies of their military
potential and the practice of
conducting nuclear exercises undermines
international security destabilizing
the situation in the world and can lead
to drastic
consequences by the way
native structures efforts
that supposedly try to face
some so-called russian threat could have
used their resources in order to
inform the europeans in detail
on these exercises for them to
understand what
uh exercises what training are taking
place
in their
air dawn or water area
for the
our nato colleagues
do it with russia
the united states practice of such
trainings
aimed at uh
preparing to implement nuclear weapons
is a flagrant violation of articles one
and two of the npt
that undermines its viability there is
only one solution to this problem
which is the withdrawal of the all
nuclear weapons of the united states to
american national territory the
destruction of the relevant
infrastructure enabling
uh to deploy such weapons
rapidly on the territory of other states
as well as the uh renunciation from
exercises aimed at
preparing uh the implementation of
nuclear weapons
by the states not possessing such kind
of weapons
i would also like to comment on the
statements by
the ministry of defense of
germany on the 20th of october the
christian democratic union of germany
published in its official twitter
account uh video address of the
minister of defense of germany
close to presidential election in
moldova on the 1st of november
the member of the german government
voiced her support for the candidacy
of the head of the party action and
solidarity
mayasana during the first coming
election we believe that such
statements represent a flagrant
violation into internal affairs of the
republic of moldova
and the statement and the claims by krem
karen boyer
on some interconnection between the
european future of the country
and going outside its borders
can be perceived only as a
flagrant black male in moldovan electors
as for the afghanistan amid the debt
and uh to which
technical issues led we note
that uh there are more and more military
clashes
including around the administrative
province of the city of flashkargach
there is a difficult military and
political situation in other regions of
afghanistan
civilians are dying the number of
refugees is increasing they call upon
the contendian african parties to
decrease
the level of violence in the countries
and to refocus on negotiations
we believe that in the nearest future a
delegation of official kabul and the
delegation of the taliban
in doha will find a consensus on
procedural issues in question and will
discuss the key
elements of the national reconciliation
agenda
we are also preoccupied with
the attacks on the headquarters of the
kurdistan
democratic party in baghdad on the 17th
of october the result of which
uh the building was vandalized and set
on fire
we are sure that it is important to
resolve
differences in iraq by force i would
like to recall once again that we are
talking about the
head quarters in baghdad
the settlement of these differences
is only possible on the basis of a
mutually
mutual respect dialect and national
reconciliation in this respect we call
upon the political forces of
iraq to be restrained and to find
solutions
around the negotiation table that would
respond to the interests of all
the professional groups of the countries
there are there is another topic
which is linked to the russian language
according to the agreements
between russia and uzbekistan regarding
the measures
to improve the quality of the russian
language teaching in the republic of
uzbekistan a group of russian
supervisors arrived in tashkent their
mission
is to launch a monitoring of the
russian language proficiency among
teachers
and pupils on the 11th of october
memorandum on adopting
the relevant joint project as well as
the basic
problem of on its uh subsequent
realization
were signed between the minister of
education of russia the ministry of
national education of uzbekistan and
non-profit
organization cherry battle foundation
art
science and sport 100 russian
specialists
are to be sent
to educational facilities in uzbekistan
and their number
is to be increased up to
1000 persons before 2013
and about 30 000 local teachers will
undergo different kinds of training
the project will be financed out of the
budget
of the russian federation and the means
of the
spec party as well as the sponsorship of
alicia rosmanov
another important point is the
inauguration in tashkent 2020 of
a representation the branch of the
russian state
university of herton
we believe that this russia uzbek
project is a real stepped
step aimed at consolidating humanitarian
ties between the peoples of our country
and in the framework of the humanitarian
project aimed
at sending russian
teachers to tajikistan about 173
teachers
i'm sorry about 50 teachers from 18
regions of russia arrived
there to teach russian language and
local schools this initiative
is aimed at improving the russian
language proficiency
in local schools it is has been
successfully implemented for four years
173 teachers from russia took
part in it teaching was carried out
in more than 20 schools in seven cities
of tajikistan and the project was highly
assessed
by the public
i would also like to recall that there
will be a forum
of harmonized international initiative
and the uh
chinese initiative one belt one way
the organizator is the
russian social organization business
russia and so on and so forth in the
framework of the first common
forum it is intended to discuss global
economic challenges
the restoration of economies after the
pandemic
also practical cooperation between the
eurasian economic union and china will
also be discussed and the delivery
of agricultural
goods uh trends transfers logistics and
other topics will be touched upon
the parties will discuss partnership
in the agricultural area heads
of foreign ministries of russia china
some countries from uh eurasian economic
union will take part in the event we
invite
everyone who is interested in this topic
to
take part in it so we specially invite
media to cover
the forum the information detailed can
be
found on the website of the forum
and during the event the key quotations
will also be published on the website
and there will be a link
to the briefing and we intend to
follow its results there is another
topic
it's a very solemn event on the 27th
of october one of the youngest state of
latin america saint vincent and
grenadines will celebrate
its anniversary it was established in
1979 today these countries country's
one of the brightest example of true
independence
and self-sufficiency
in having unchanged position in
defending the u.n
charter norms and principles of
international law its candidacy
as a non-permanent member of the u.n
security council
was supported by 185 states
which elected this country as a
non-permanent uh security council member
for the period of 2020 2021
and uh despite all the circumstances
the voice didn't shake because of the
pressure we would like to note
the harmonization of our positions in
the u.n security council and the general
assembly for us it's one of the closest
partners in the caribbeans
and so we are delightful to recall
the visit paid to moscow by the
country's
prime minister ralph gonzalez i would
like to use this occasion to
congratulate our friends on behalf of
the ministry and to wish
them peace prosperity and well-being
today would like to proceed
to the questions please
i would like to give the floor
to news front please his news front
represented here
yes it is
this sound please there is no sound
i don't hear you could you
start speaking please hello
hello international information
agency news front
the bulgarian office marie vladimir if
you'll
have two questions linked
to the nagorno-karabakh settlement
i apologize but bearing in mind
the developments there
the first question is linked to this
statement
a person who said that we can stay the
death of the brain of the osce means
group
it is true that the means group has so
far provided no
good initiative how does russia assess
such a statement made by turkey when
such an active work aimed at cessation
of fire in the gordon current is being
carried out so dynamically
do you have another question you said
that you had two questions
yes i have there is another question
which is
also linked to the nebular back
settlement
i'm talking about the anti-terrorist
operation
and the head of the committee on
international affairs
of the council federation mr kosichov
who said that in order to conduct such
an
anti-terrorist operation in
nagorno-karabakh it was necessary
for armenia to make an official address
to russia with the regard of such
operation and the participation of
foreign militants in the conflict
and taken into account the existence of
such a terrorist
threat do you think that such a
peacekeeping
operation in nagorno-karabakh is
necessary
and what steps will russia take having
such a great experience in this area
i didn't get you quite fully let's
answer the first question i would like
to tell you
that there are many statements now about
uh the
karabakh settlement i think
i think we must uh select
which statements we comment on we must
consider a different tactic
consider the official position of moscow
on this question
it is unchangeable you know it very well
[Music]
it is also supplemented by concrete
steps and actions
about the mains group of osce we have
announced
just today another step in its work
i think it's
it is better than comments
now to the second questions honestly i
didn't quite get it
your exact wording what exactly must i
comment on
the statement of mr kosichov i think
doesn't deserve any
other comment it's pretty
self-explanatory
i think there are no additions from me
required
you must reformulate you probably should
reformulate the question
in that case if there are
any real threats to spread terrorism
due to transferring terrorists in the
region
i understand now i can say now that
military experts
of corresponding ministries
control this question quite attentively
it this question worries us we've
mentioned it quite a lot of times
i can assure you that there is a lot of
work going on
because this issue is a real
a real problem for us so we pay a lot of
attention to it
thank you
open tv greece
i would like to also ask a question
about the militants but it's already
been asked
so what's your estimation of situation
with
militants from the middle east that are
fighting in karabakh
can you add something to this discussion
i have questions like who ships them
what's the reason for your statement
towards other countries to
those states who help transfer them to
this region
what the russian diplomacy hopes for in
this situation
that these countries will just ship them
back
you know the russian diplomacy
the instruments they already have in
their work
those aren't just uh null based
hopes that concrete expectations
this consists of public statements and
concrete works and practical actions we
are in contact with our colleagues
who have in some way or another involved
in situations in the region
i would like to mention once again that
the theme
of militants that have been transferred
to this region is being worked on
through external diplomatic channels
and of course or maybe primarily
our military experts russian village
experts
are being involved in this work as you
clearly know
this work definitely doesn't require
additional attention from the from
public public must be
convinced that this work is going on i
will
just note once again that this is a
concrete issue
we understand as i said very clearly the
possible implications of this situation
why haven't we discussed this publicly
well to give this problem
a different dimension and underline
its importance for our country
just because we clearly understand what
the consequences are
but the public side of this discussion
is secondary
primarily must focus on the work that's
been carried out
thank you
the next question please
i have a question a bit more specific
yesterday prime minister of armenia
said that karabakh conflict has no
peaceful solution
russia in its turn
conducts my bilateral and neutral this
meetings to solve the conflict
how would you comment the yesterday's
statement
highlight that there are just an
incredible number of statements right
now
we clearly understand why because
situation is really tense
it's the active phase of conflict after
all
it's a bloody face of bloodshed people
die
servicemen civilians die
but at the same time you clearly know
the russian position has been
voiced more than on one occasion
by the leadership of the mfa
i think it has found broad support in
among the public
opposition is we need to stop the
bloodshed
and immediately start negotiations
and of course
our position has been unchanged
you know it's
you know it hasn't changed
also we had a question from the
information against the international
agency
impacted an important important
influence on the
construct cooperation between iran and
russia
despite the covenant pandemic wrestle
iranian
connections have been going on
and improving this year the president of
the
two of the countries have phoned each
other four times
and there have been multiple telephone
conversations between the
between uh mr veladen the chairman of
the state duma
and the chairman of the
council of islamic soviet of iran
then there will be meetings of country
guarantees in tehran
after the elimination of political
situation our
leadership and rancidity ship also
focuses on the problem
of spread of the kopit-19 and the
perspective of
practical cooperation on the russian
vaccine sputnik v
and also we are aiming at a profile
dialogue
during the pandemic we mark positive
dynamics
in business relations the growth of
trade and we intend to
promote cooperation to the countries and
promote realization of our mutual
potential and also one other question
can iran and russia cooperate in solving
the karma conflict
do these two countries work uh
around the situation in south caucasus
russian federation and the islamic
republic of
iran have a long history of multifaceted
friendly relations
have been always aimed at the creation
of necessary
conditions for peace and stability in
the region both countries are interested
in good neighborly relations
in the region and the so that
any disputes could be solved at the
table of negotiations
based on u.n charter the escalation in
qarabak region has been discussed by the
russian and iranian leadership
on high-profile levels
weak we can state an affinity in
opposition
around this question that the
ceasefire is necessary we know that eren
supports
daily efforts of russia i can say this
for sure their leader of efforts of
russia
and its national uh capacity or in
in in the men's group of osce
we are attentively considering
the dependence of the iranian side now
parties will understand that the
bloodshed is not the answer
another question pakistan news channel
92 news what's the position of the
russian federation regarding the
domination of relations between
united arab emirates and israel and the
restoration of
aircraft
between the two countries is a
continuation of
efforts to achieve a just complex and
true settlement of
conflict between israel and palestine we
think that it's important to respect the
sovereign affairs of
sovereign states and not interfere in
their internal affairs
and we call on all middle eastern
countries to respect those principles
we would like to express our concerns
about uh
[Music]
who approved the plan to expand israeli
settlements in the west bank
these plans include building
the wall of security in east jerusalem
this means an annex
an annexation of palestinian territories
we express our support for the two-state
solution of palestinian problem and we
appeal for this
speedy improv direct negotiation between
israel and palestine under the ages of
u.n so as to resolve the final status
and achieve
comprehensive and sustainable settlement
another question agency agent news about
the
question of uh withdrawal of troops from
afghanistan already
mentioned this so let's just uh return
to this again
thinks that the mere presence of these
forces
is destabilizing
as we know the taliban movement
considers the nato
movement nato forces and afghanistan and
the occupation forces
the full withdrawal of forces from
afghanistan and
agreements in the inclusive into
afghanistan
dialogue is a necessary precondition for
sustainable peace in the country me just
check for a minute
we have no other questions that's all if
you have no other questions
i thank you for your attention i wish
you well and would like also to mention
that
upcoming visits to the balkans in greece
this interviews will come soon thank you
you